make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are continuing with Doomsday
Clock God this story is taking like two
years to come out okay the cool thing is
that the big takeaway from the last
issue was basically it was like dr.
Manhattan fighting against the Justice
League it was really more just toying
with him that was the craziest thing
about the last issue almost all the
Earth's superheroes come rolling in on
Mars to like confront dr. Manhattan and
he's just kind of toying with him and is
like okay I'm bored now and just waves
his hand and they're all incapacitated
right there's just like this grandiose
display of how painfully outmatched they
are against someone with the kind of
power that dr. Manhattan has but the
great thing about this story is it picks
up with what's essentially classic
misdirection right like it picks up with
this old this old film ah there's really
just referred to as like the adjournment
right like the adjournment is basically
like this film is being shot with a
couple of people one of which is Harvard
Coleman and for the most part he's just
kind of considered to be inept to a
degree right like he's basically an
actor that just can't pull it off as is
really what it kind of seems to be hit
out here like it's it's taken 12 takes
and he keeps forgetting what his line is
supposed to be and the funny thing about
this is that again like with dr.
Manhattan he doesn't he never released
he doesn't see time linearly the same
way we do right like we don't know what
tomorrow holds we have to wait until
tomorrow gets here to find out right
it's like that it's like that rule you
get off work at 7:00 a.m. and you go to
bed and you go to sleep people will say
well it's already tomorrow no tomorrow
starts when I wake up like that's the
way the world works and so because of
that with Manhattan seeing everything
happening all at the same time for him
like a vincit ER is supposed to happen
for us have already happened for him you
know he just sees them he just knows how
it's going to turn out and so being able
to see time simultaneously means that
again we sort of bounce around here now
of course we'll do this in a way that
that essentially makes sense but but for
Carver Coleman himself again he's kind
of considered to be like a nonsensical
doctor and on top of all that he's
basically being blackmailed now of
course we end up finding out the person
that's blackmailing him is his mom again
these are just kind of smaller points
here in their in reality just kind of
sets the stage for the struggle of
Carver to kind of show us the nature of
his character what is it he's going
through he is kind of a centerpiece but
not the definitive centerpiece instead
what is up happening here is when he's
blackmailed blackmail by his mom you
know following up with that he basically
gets up gets like all the the lines
everything down perfectly so whatever
was said between the two of them the
indication is that it has a pretty
significant impact on him and so from
there we basically end up switching over
to like dr. Manhattan himself and this
is cool because what he does is he
actually sort of kind of recollect sir
it really seems to flashback among his
own memories right
bringing Laurie the second so expect her
to Mars and of course she suffocates and
he gives her the ability to breathe and
so I'm just kind of like jumping through
these small little moments here and
there and it's kind of a cool thing
because then ultimately it basically
settles when he first arrived in the
main DC Universe on April 18th 1938 now
for those people who were familiar with
the history of DC Comics this date will
strike you in particular and the reason
why is because this is almost exactly
three months before the arrival of
Superman right like actually Comics
number one debuted in June of 1938 so
this is almost three months exactly
before a Superman pops up on the scene
and and again kind of focused being put
here on on Carver Coleman this notion
that like he's a little kid that his mom
really seems to be like a prostitute
more or less and then he gets a job
working at a at a picture studio just
working in the mailroom that eventually
like the building burns down after he
catches his boss essentially with
another man which back then was
considered to be taboo and of course
he's basically fired he ends up being
homeless and then of he's essentially
like you know ran up on by some cops who
really start beating the crap out of him
and then dr. Manhattan shows up and
that's when Manhattan begins to
basically find his anchor in in the DC
Universe and this is an important thing
because when it comes to Manhattan in in
really like The Watchmen universe he's
essentially disconnected from humanity
right he's just kind of like I'm bored
of people but with Manhattan leaving the
Watchmen universe and then coming over
to to this universe basically it's him
just kind of going through and saying
okay like I'm exploring the multiverse
now right I was the whole thing like I
just kind of broke into the multiverse
to go look at different things but it's
this idea that he's essentially starting
over right like he's it's almost like a
like a scientific experiment it's
starting over again he's somewhat
invested in it because he wants to learn
what all this is about
and that's when he starts speaking with
Carver and Carver almost addresses him
as like an angel or God and someone the
two of them sit down which is actually
kind of an interesting power that I
didn't really know Manhattan had he
actually refract light around himself to
essentially changes up here so that this
woman this waitress sees what he wants
her to see which I mean I guess for a
guy that can control the atomic
structure of matter it makes sense but
nonetheless in his discussions with
Carver what he does is really just kind
of give him like these small little bits
of information about things that'll
happen later on down the line this is
kind of a funny thing here and the
reason why is because we don't initially
find out what it is that he told him all
we know is that between the time that
Carver basically went to Hollywood to
try to become an actor and then
ultimately became a paperboy lost his
job and then got his job in the in the
adjournment they're basically like
Manhattan spoke to him and talked to him
now
here's why this matters is because again
Coleman is as anchor to humanity it's
through Coleman that Manhattan begins to
sort of understand what people are like
in this universe right because there's
no assumption it's the same thing
there's no assumption that like that
when they show up here that that or at
least when he shows up here that it's
gonna be the exact same thing as the
Watchmen universe it's an impartial just
sort of looking at things and seeing how
they unfold but in the midst of all this
suddenly Manhattan is basically like he
overhears this conversation about some
guy you know basically like some guy in
Metropolis who picked up a car over his
head the introduction of Superman and he
immediately takes off because from that
point it becomes a question of okay so
basically I've traveled back to the
moment when Superman first pops up and
he actually watches the events unfold he
witnesses the events take place now this
is kind of a funny thing here because
the indication is that when this happens
when Superman picks up his car he looks
back and basically like glances at
Manhattan but he doesn't seem to see
Manhattan or if he does that he just
kind of smirks her or what have you now
a lot of that kind of goes into the idea
that I he had this smile on his face you
know was what they were saying when he
picked up the car as it was kind of a
cool thing because what Manhattan does
is literally start going through and
saying okay so Superman seems to be
where my life ends right that's the main
brunt of the story so far is that the
last thing Manhattan sees is Superman
flying at him in a neo absolutely pissed
off and then everything goes black and
he doesn't know if it goes black because
Superman kills him or if it goes black
because he wipes everything out and so
he really just kind of begins to sort of
look at the timeline as it was supposed
to be right 'ln and this is kind of the
cool thing that in the in in 1940 that
Alan Scott was basically you know on a
like a railway guy I mean they came
across the Green Lantern picked it up
and used it and then it basically saved
him from this train crash that was gonna
happen that that in in January of around
the same year Jay Garrick falls asleep
neo and is exposed to heavy water and
ends up becoming you know the the flash
Jay Garrick the same thing with Carter
Hall becoming Hawkman without Pratt
becoming the atom Kent Nelson becoming
dr. fate with Wesley Dodds becoming
Sandman with Jim Corrigan becoming
becoming the specter these origins of
these characters you know as he knows
them and as he's seen them unfold and
Denis switches over to the formation of
the JSA and this is a cool thing because
there's actually some history that Geoff
Johns pulls out here so when the JSA
meets what they do is they they kind of
start talking about like their role as
Karadzic Oh what are they going to do as
heroes and for the most part they're not
wildly familiar with each other they're
just kind of oh where the other is there
now this is kind of a cool thing because
what this does is it basically hits it
like what's essentially the first
crossover between these characters
now back in the day the JSA was was
tried and true the first real coming
together of a singular team like
all-star comics you know the idea of a
team sort of banding together now the
original JSA as it existed back in All
Star Comics number three was actually a
team-up and that's one of the reasons
why it's so cool is because truthfully
Superman number 76 is what a lot of
people point out when they say DC first
established their shared universe but
it's kind of but not really and the
reason why is because all these
characters that you see were created by
all-star publications and then the DC
side or at least the the Batman Superman
side was national allied publications it
was almost kind of like Marvel and DC so
to speak right so I mean like eventually
all-star in national allied join
together and they became Detective
Comics Incorporated but essentially this
was a sister publication now the
difference is that national allied and
all Americans shared characters right
like they were they would go back and
forth with characters but Wonder Woman
Alan Scott the original Green Lantern
Jay Garrick the original flash the
specter of these guys they were all
all-star comics and so in reality it was
kind of a shared universe strictly
within All Star Comics that's why
Superman number 76 and the formation of
a shared universe in that story the fact
that Gotham and metropolis both exists
on the same earth and that Batman as
Superman can cross over with each other
the reason why that was so big is
because that was the first time we've
seen that going into what was
essentially Detective Comics
incorporated the merging of national
allied and All Star Comics so again
that's that's why that little bit of
history there is significant but with
this team meeting up and this team
basically talking one of the things they
say is we need to find Superman and this
is kind of a cool thing because back
then when this when this was really kind
of being launched again it was for the
most part hands-off and while they did
share characters and the popularity of
Superman and Batman could have
essentially carried over to the JSA the
issue was that it wasn't and the reason
why was because they were afraid of
overexposure right because you have the
Superman comics and you had action you
had the Batman comics and you had
Detective and then not only that you
actually had Superboy that was running
around going on around the same time
both national allied and All Star were
afraid that if Superman and Batman
appeared in the JSA in addition to the
other publications they had the people
would get burned out on them but the
fact remains that like when they're
going through and they're looking at
this moment suddenly everything shifts
and it goes back to when you had Johnny
Thunder first started the picture and
saying like okay the team's all here
let's get our picture guys no one knows
who Superman is no one knows who he is
where he where he was where he's from or
anything like that essentially Superman
doesn't seem to exist and that's kind of
the crazy thing is because what he does
is dr. Manhattan travel
back to two essentially where Superman
first crash-landed in Smallville and
then of course it kind of goes through a
little bit of his origin story now we
don't really have to do this per se
because it's the origin story of
Superman right he's discovered by John
and Martha Kent they raised him
eventually they died but the thing is is
like John and Martha have died in
various ways over the years that they've
died when when like Jonathan just died
of old age they've died when they were
killed in a car crash they died when
they both died of old age like they've
both died under different circumstances
and usually it's the result of a reboot
and that's exactly what Manhattan hits
on when Manhattan goes through all these
different stories of Superman it says
okay well John died in this circumstance
and then Martha died in that
circumstance and then John and Martha
both died in this particular
circumstance that what he's basically
doing here is he's looking at this and
saying okay if Superman goes on to
become a character that embodies hope
then let's see how far out this goes and
so what he does is he jumps all the way
to the 31st century right like when
Superboy is first brought to that era by
the Legion of super-heroes again a major
arc for Superboy back in the day when he
became like the sort of major superhero
that dealt with more than just what
Superman was doing when he was a kid and
as the Legion begins to talk to him what
we end up having is a scenario where
where dr. Manhattan says okay fine then
let's see what happens if I change
things so he removes the lantern from
Alan Scott's grasp and what it does is
it creates this cascading effect the
death of Alan Scott the fact that he
doesn't show up basically leads to all
these various characters not existing
Superman never is never taken to the
31st century as Superboy meaning that
point in time never really seems to
happen instead it just kind of flash
forwards a little bit and then it shows
like the new 52 origin where John and
Martha Kent are basically killed in a
car crash so again like it's one of
these things where Manhattan goes back
he looked into the future it says okay
the legacy of Superman lasts well into
the 31st century so let's see what
happens if we change things that what
Manhattan does is he looks down and he
says this universe as it exists this DC
universe is singular it's one of a kind
human beings on this planet perceived
the multiverse as basically like a a
sort of branch universe theory right
like what if Superman landed in Russia
instead of the United States well then
you get red Sun Superman but it's a
branch off of the existing universe
that's the way it works but what he says
is that this universe is constantly
changing it's constantly in flux it's
not as though this universe came into
existence and then is basically
maintained its exact same form ever
since it was first created we've had
crisis on Infinite Earths
we've had Infinite Crisis we've had
Final Crisis we've had zero our prices
entire
and we've had the events of Flashpoint
happen this universe has constantly
changed by one real for one reason or
another and when it did it shuffled up
the timeline things suddenly vanish but
that's the question that a lot of people
had people would sit down and they would
say okay so my question is this if
crisis on Infinite Earths happened it
was essentially a reboot coming out of
crisis on Infinite Earths basically
there was only a singular universe and
everybody gets new origins then what
happened to things before that Thetas
vanished they were just gone one day
that was it
the original origin story of the JSA as
it existed in 1940 and also our comics
number three was wiped away what you got
was the version of the JSA post-crisis
that originally appeared where they were
basically heroes that fought during
world war ii that's the nature of what's
kind of going on here is this idea that
like all these other universes that
exist out there they do branch off this
universe but the reason why they branch
off is because the main DC Universe is
changing all the time it's constantly in
flux and that's what Manhattan looks and
that's why he did his experiment is
because he said I look at this the
history of this universe and I see the
flash Barry Allen who initiated the
flashpoint I see like the anti-monitor I
see accident I see all these things
ranging from the original crisis to zero
hour all three running up until you know
the events of Flashpoint
and I see all these major changes that
take place so if they can mess up the
timeline then so can i I'm just gonna
use it as a grand experiment and just
see what happens it's a kid with an ant
farm is basically what this is now the
funny thing is he says like there are a
couple instances when like the universe
tried to fight back right so like Wally
West realized what was going on and
tried to break out of the Speed Force to
basically confront Manhattan and was
forced back into it again and that goes
into the events of DC Universe rebirth
number one when Barry remembers who he
is
and essentially brings him back but the
cool thing about that is that when that
happens a lot of Wally's memories were
kind of thrown into flux or wiped away
entirely
he doesn't remember any of it and that's
kind of the crazy thing here is because
when he looks at this he kind of looks
at humanity and again he looks at Carver
Coleman and he says like you're going to
die we end up finding out he was
basically killed by his mom using an
award that he won but dr. Manhattan
again kind of returns back to his
disconnect is kinda like okay so
basically is still pretty much the same
thing here like and this universe is the
same thing as the other sure they have
like super-powered beings but at the end
of the day it's all still basically the
same thing these humans running around
with these irrelevant problems that they
think are super important but they're
not because they don't really see the
grand scheme of things and their
problems are no more important in the
problems of anybody else but they think
it's the most significant thing in the
world because they believe the world
revolves around them and that's kind of
the cool thing here that's what's so
awesome about that is it basically sits
down and
says in this universe that I live in
with these experiments that I've done
with the way that I've toyed with things
way that I've screwed things up and mess
with these people's lives in this
universe of hope that literally revolves
around Superman I've essentially become
the villain and it's kind of a cool
thing he doesn't say it because he
really thinks he's a bad guy it's really
just kind of like this internal
discussion that he has I'm basically the
villain here I'm basically the bad guy
I've literally been screwing up the
timestream it's focusing on the nature
of Manhattan why has he done what he's
done because he came into this universe
he realized that like this universe is
special in the sense of every other
universe and the multiverse branches off
of it and in that the universe is
constantly changing so the question is
what happens if you change things too
fast what happens if you change things
in the extreme what will happen with
this universe it's a science project is
basically what it is so again the
question still is still lingering does
document hatton destroy this universe or
does Superman destroy dr. Manhattan
that's the question that's really the
question that's being asked here and
it's the one that we're probably gonna
have to wait like five years to get an
answer to but without being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to come as explain
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
you